when you're performing and you're not in
front of a live audience how do you know
that your character's working how do you
know that you're having an effect
whether it's comedic dramatic
sometimes you don't
sometimes you just don't
um
i've
i've seen the final
product on television or
in a in a theater sometimes and i'm
thinking oh that
they didn't laugh there where they were
supposed to where we thought they would
or um it just didn't have the emotional
impact that uh
that we thought it would have
um most of the time you can you can tell
you're
you're depending on the chemistry you
have with the other actors and if it's
authentic and it's real
um
you just know that you can it's an
organic feeling that
is just so present there that you just
know it you know it but
sometimes you don't
you can't hit a home run every time
and um
even though
the business expects you to
uh sometimes you just don't
so do you do you
cry yourself to sleep and and quit the
business
no you just get back up on the horse and
and try it again the next time
were you ever one of those actors that
could not watch themselves on screen
that would have to leave during the
premiere
oh no no i i love to watch myself
um
i just don't like to watch myself during
dailies because i don't think i'm the
best judge of how
how that whole frame of information is
is working because i can only see one
tiny part of it myself
no i
sure i like to i like to see myself
you're able to see because you know we
talked about it before you only see
yourself as you and and all your years
on the planet and you know yourself and
ins and outs
what about people that can't watch
themselves is that is again that's their
choice don't you think that maybe
they're harming themselves by not seeing
who they are well i think
look i you know am i happy with
every performance that i give and the
way i look
um on screen every time i see myself no
no i'm not i
you know
um
either the
the camera angle was not flattering
sometimes
or
the makeup was a little too trowelled on
and
doesn't look that great or
you know who knows any variety of things
um mostly technical that
or and and sometimes i've just given
performances that i'd you know that felt
good at the time but then when i finally
see them
just
didn't quite hit the note that i wanted
them to hit and and i think every actor
goes through that
um
but and and but you asked me what what
do you do just
you you just get over it
get over it
it's not that big a deal right you know
and again
you can't feel your own handshake
it's not
there there's a lot of other
stuff
involved in that scene or that
uh or that entire project that um
that doesn't have to do with you
so it's not
it's not that big a deal
in terms of us not being able to see how
maybe the rest of the world sees us
do you think it's important to get
feedback from casting directors or you
know do some of these workshops where
people kind of find your type so you can
know maybe maybe you think you're one
type and they see you with something
else they see you more as an army
general or you know a banker or
something like well you know i do cowboy
i do a lot of judges and
governors
um
lawyers
stuff like that
um did you always see yourself as that
time maybe you thought you were a fly
fish no i saw yourself i thought of
myself as a romantic lead for you know
at one time and and um
but i think one of the most important
things an actor can do is to have that
self-awareness
an actor needs to know
what his type is and what his brand is
his or her brand and type
and
um
i i just i i i can't emphasize how
important that's been for me
um and it guides me in decisions that my
agent has in submitting me for things as
well sometimes i'll say no please don't
submit me for this because oh why she's
i think you'd be i think he'd be
terrific for this no no
trust me this is not in my wheelhouse
not that i i have to you know be safe in
every project i think it's also
tremendously important to
um
push the envelope and
and try things that i'm not confident
with and and that are scary for me
um
that
that scene that val kilmer and i had in
the front seat of the car was an example
of that
um
were you always self-aware they always
say that that's the mark of a very
successful person what other whatever
industry is self-awareness that's one of
the main things well
you know you watch the american idol
auditions and you see people who have
zero self-awareness they cannot hear
themselves
sing
they think they sound like
like pavarotti and
they sound like a screeching cat instead
and they
there's no self-awareness there i don't
know how you i mean it's either a
blessing to go through life that way
or a curse i don't know which one it is
um
well if you think well of yourself i
guess it's probably yeah blessings yeah
uh
yeah but i think uh for actors we do
have to have
a certain
sense of self-awareness that i think
the more developed it is the better it
serves us
are there exercises in self-awareness
because what if someone maybe they grew
up with blinders on and now they're in
this big city and and it's a whole new
experience and
all their life they were oh you're this
dear and patted on the head and coddled
and then they come here and it's a whole
rude awakening well i mean reality is a
a cruel mistress sometimes and and
sometimes um yeah you just have to be
slapped in the face with the truth
uh sometimes and if you're constantly
going out and and
uh auditioning for
uh one thing
and nobody is casting you i mean nobody
is ever offering you roles
of the type that you think you should be
playing
and they're offering they're constantly
offering you roles of a type that you
don't think you should be playing i mean
come on
get a clue clue phone's ringing it's for
you
maybe you ought to consider this this
other this other look that uh this other
type that
you've been repudiating up until this
point
aside from that i mean that's that's a
great you know analogy of that but are
there other ways to develop your
self-awareness maybe just through youth
you just think uh it'll all turn out and
it's all going to be great
so i never did this but somebody
suggested this to me once in a class and
i i think it's a good idea
um
set up a have a couple of pictures of
yourself on a card table and set up the
card table at a mall or someplace like
that where you maybe get away with
something like that and just as people
pass by
ask them
um
what job do they think you you what what
your occupation is just by looking at
the pictures what occupation does this
person have
and
write down the responses and generally
speaking
they'll all fall into one or two or
three different categories and they'll
all be kind of similar and that's a good
way to
see yourself as others see you
interesting yeah yeah
i
i never did it and i kind of wish i had
done it but
i don't think it would have changed
anything because i
i do know what i look like and
what my
what my strong points are i think if i
have any
you